c'était écran global documentaire auquel
vous pouvez bien sûr réagir sur le
hashtag docu des bars documentaire
réalisé par vous anne-sophie
lévy-chambon merci d'être là à vos côtés
serge tisseron
vous êtes psychiatre est docteur en
psychologie psychanalyste merci d'être
avec nous en face de vous dominique
boullier bonjour vous êtes professeur
des universités en sociologie
responsable de la pédagogie numérique à
sciences po et membre du media lab et
enfin benoît thieulin bonjour vous êtes
président du conseil national du
numérique fondateur et directeur de
l'agencé digitale la netscouade
bienvenue à tous alors anne sophie lévy
chambon
c'est en en vo enfants à l'école un
matin oui qu'est née l'idée de ce
documentaire raconte et nous ça
absolument c'est il ya deux choses au
fait la première je ne voulais pas de
smartphone en fait au départ je
pressentais que c'était un outil qui
pouvait induire des comportements un
petit peu addictif dirons nous donc j'en
ai eu un et en me réveillant je me suis
rendu compte qu'il avait un petit peu
envahi toutes les pièces de ma vie et
puis un matin j'emmène mes enfants à
l'école et ce matin là j'ai vu des
smartphones partout c'est voilà parfois
quand on regarde ce qui se passe dans la
rue donc les gens marchaient avec leur
smartphone
j'ai tourné il y avait un café il y
avait la télévision tout le monde
regardait la télévision le matin quand
je suis arrivé pour mettre les chaussons
des petits à l'école tous les parents
étaient avec leur smartphone en train de
mettre les choses aux je me suis dit
mais qu'est ce qui se passe
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'arrive plus à
lâcher en fait à se séparer
j'ai vraiment eu cette image de ma fille
avec son doudou et les parents avec leur
smartphone et je me suis dit peut-être
quelque chose quand même qui est un
petit peu qui nous qui nous accapare
trop et alors ce documentaire est ce
qu'il a changé votre comportement est ce
que quelqu es les faits il a eu sur vous
alors déjà j'ai pris une décision
radicale qui est que mon smartphone ne
rentre plus dans ma chambre à coucher
ça c'était vraiment cessé ses bêtes ça
paraît bête mais je crois qu'il faut se
s'imposer des règles et des limites et
donc je le branche est juste à côté de
mon lit
c'est quelque chose que je ne fais plus
il est interdit voilà ce smartphone de
rentrer dans la chambre ça n'est pas le
lieu de ça donc je le branche dans le
salon et ça va beaucoup mieux
et c'est vrai qu'il ya une autre chose
c'est quand je rentre je le mets sur
silencieux et je regarde une fois que
j'ai terminé de faire les choses mais je
ne suis plus en train de préparer le
dîner avec mon smartphone vous utilisez
vous me direz ce nouveau message et à
travers justement ce documentaire on
vous sent effectivement assez méfiante
et peut-être même un peu critique
qu'est-ce qui vous inquiète vraiment en
fait la captation de la tension et la
diminution de la présence à soi et aux
autres
en fait c'est à dire que ce sont des
outils qui restent des outils c'est ce
qu'on en fait donc on est absolument
responsable de ça mais ce sont des
outils qui nous accapare et qui ont une
sorte de pouvoir de superpuissance qui
est qu' on est attiré par l'écran et ça
c'est juste normal ces visuels ça bouge
c'est coloré notre cerveau fonctionne
comme ça donc c'est tout à fait naturel
entre guillemets mais c'était cette
captation de l'attention et c'est pour
ça que je pense que c'est important
d'apprendre à les éteindre et qu'il ne
faut pas qu'ils soient allumés tout le
temps et qu'il faut s'imposer un certain
nombre de règles pour les enfants pour
la famille pour le travail et sa touche
tous les domaines de la société on va en
parler alors vous avez choisi de traiter
la question du numérique avec le mot
écran est-ce que l'on peut rassembler
internet jeuxvideo réseaux sociaux et
leur support derrière ce seul mot écran
qu'elle prend la parole d'ami goulet a
écouté je trouve que dans le film
justement on voit bien cela c'est à dire
qu'au départ on part d'une notion
globale sur les écrans tous les écrans
partout et puis y compris la
présentation vous venez d'en faire en
réalité c'est le smartphone sur lequel
on se focalise parce que c'est quand
même pas c'est différent oui et c'est un
peu la même chose en général contre du
numérique
ça devient quand même un peu plus
intéressant quand il dans le film on
voit cette progression là y compris dans
les jeux vidéo vous parlais au début on
dit les jeux vidéo ils y apprendront
qu'il ya des jeux vidéo et des choses
très différentes
donc le film est intéressant pour
justement sortir des stéréotypes ou des
2 comment dire des réactions un peu
spontané pour se dire oui mais
choisissons voyons ce qui à l'intérieur
voyons comment c'est fait et dans les
comportements y compris bien oui
évidemment on
le désavantage du smartphone ce sont les
notifications c'est cet aspect moi ce
que j'appelle ce régime de l' alerte
qu'un régime d'attention justement vous
êtes en permanence en alerte
c'est un grand bénéfice mais si vous
n'avez plus que ce régime d'attention
évidemment il ya un problème
vous devenez prisonniers et on appelle
ça un peu ivan illitch appeler ça
effectivement ça c'est le monopole
technologique au bout d'un moment vous
devez 4 ne vous devenez captif de cela
donc l'intérêt c'est précisément et on
voit très bien ce ça dans le film on
voit les choses se complexifier et se
dire oui mais il ya plusieurs façon de
faire il ya plusieurs et à ce moment là
on n'est plus dans les grandes causes si
vous voulez qui nous lient au numérique
qui nous tombe dessus en faire non on
commence à se poser pour comprendre
exactement et on peut choisir on peut
sélectionner là dedans et il faut donc
faut donc examiner cas par cas ce qu'on
en fait dans nos comportements comme
dans les types d'applications les types
de techniciens intéressant en la matière
à une réaction oui je crois que je crois
que le mobile en fête est devenu une
espèce de deux couteaux suisses en fait
numérique qui al'avantage parce qu'il
est tout petit et qui les mobiles d'être
en permanence avec nous ce qui est en
fait engendre une transformation sur le
majeur dans notre société enfin je veux
dire d'automne et du tout juste au
commencement pour autant partie de
pression parce que c'est un couteau
suisse en faire plein de choses
extrêmement vivante ne serait ce que ce
petit outil lui même peut être utilisé
pour lire pour répondre pour acheter
pour cuisiner mais en lisant il restait
du cuivre et donc la difficulté
effectivement c'est de savoir justement
ne pas se laisser au fond venus minées
par le support lui-même mais bien de
réfléchir derrière au fond quels sont
les types d' usage qu'on a et du coup
d'avoir au fond un rapport maîtrisé face
à tout ça c'est à dire qu'au fond on
distingue selon les usages ce que l'on
en fait et du coup je pense que c'est
très important au moment des ans cette
transformation absolument à mon avis
sans précédent précisant qu'on débatte
de ces sujets là et qu'on sorte je
dirais des débats un peu simpliste et un
peu caricaturaux qu'on a eu c'est normal
à l'émergence de ce phénomène premier à
dire tu as qu on est pour ou est-ce
qu'on est contre enfin on peut rentrer
dans le vrai sujet aujourd'hui qui est
dire lesquels et le numérique que nous
voulons quand est ce que nous voulons
quand est ce que ça apporte des fruits
et et on va dire des bénéfices
incroyables quand est-ce que ça pose
plus de problème est d'ailleurs sur bien
de ces questions en réalité aujourd'hui
on n'a pas forcément toujours de
réponses très prudents expérimentation
tests et interrogations que vous le
faites très bien être
et et distant anne-sophie votre
questionnement vous l'avez dit porte
aussi sur le rapport à l'autre sur le
rapport à soi serge tisseron notre
comportement social est il différent
déjà aujourd'hui d'avant l'arrivée du
numérique
oui alors d'abord je voulais reprendre
les questions que vous avez posé avant
parce qu'on a bien vu que il ya
plusieurs types d'écran il ya beaucoup
d' usage possible voilà il faut
apprendre à bien utiliser les écrans
mais ce qu'on voit bien aussi dans le
film d'anne sophie c'est que finalement
il ya des tranches d'âge et que chaque
tranche d'âge doit être introduite aux
écrans au bon moment et de la bonne
manière ça je vais vous interrogez donc
ça c'est très important parce que les
écrans bon on sait bien que c'est
formidable
anne sophie lemée 20 dans sa chambre
mais le reste du temps elle assure l on
sait combien c'est important mais ce
qu'on sait aussi c'est que pour qu'un
enfant puisse bien les utiliser il faut
pas qu'il en ait été envahi trop tôt et
donc du coup il ya une pédagogie des
écrans pour nous adultes voilà apprendre
à bien les gérer connaître les
applications mais il ya aussi toute une
pédagogie à voir dans les écoles et dans
les familles et c'est ce sur quoi on
arrive et demande en quelques minutes
mais sur le rapport à l'autre serge
tisseron je voulais vous entends est ce
que vous constatez vous je vous
travaillez beaucoup sur ce sujet là
depuis depuis de nombreuses années notre
notre sociabilité notre notre rapport à
l'autre a évolué ou est-ce que ou est-ce
que c'est l'évolution sociologique
simple de notre de notre société qui
modifie les comportements est ce que
l'outil numérique a à lui seul modifier
les comportements
alors oui bien évidemment est à bord
internet
l'avènement d'internet c'est le fait que
vous allez pas seulement chercher une
information comme bouvier faire dans une
encyclopédie traditionnellement où près
d'un mètre
mais vous allez chercher une information
que vous pouvez donner votre avis sur
les informations nouvelles dans un forum
et donc du coup aujourd'hui on
s'aperçoit que les enfants grandissent
dans un an
où ils ont une représentation du savoir
différentes montrent plus collaboratif
plus participatif
alors faut reconnaître que l'éducation
nationale en france à peine à prendre ce
chemin mais des gens c'est une
modification qui s'installe dans
l'esprit des enfants du fait de
l'utilisation d'internet
alors il ya le fait aussi du téléphone
mobile pouvoir joindre quelqu'un à tout
moment être joint à tout moment donc ça
peut générer le meilleur comme le pire
un le pire c'est le fait de d'être en
grande souffrance quand on a pas
l'interlocuteur qu'on veut au moment où
on ne veut mais le meilleur est bon on
le sait chacun d'entre nous c'est la
possibilité de joindre des gens pour des
choses importantes qu'on n'aurait pas pu
joindre autrement c'est dans les usages
en fait il faut comprendre que si vous
êtes si vous êtes en grande souffrance
ou aller de la peine vous socialiser
vous risquez bien d'utiliser internet
pour vous désocialise est encore plus
mais si vous avez un bon réseau social
vous êtes curieux des autres curieux du
monde bat internet va devenir un
formidable outil pour développer ce sens
collaboratif et participatif
alors en quelques années un outil
numérique donc s'est largement imposé
dans la vie à ceux qui sont nés avec
qu'on appelle les digital natives ya
ceux qui ont grandi avec et puis il ya
ceux qui apprennent à l'utiliser en
l'offrant à leurs enfants ce sont des
utilisations et des perceptions
différentes mais en tout état de cause
il va bien falloir qu'on s'adapte alors
comment donner à ces outils leur juste
place on réécoute un extrait de votre
documentaire
en fait on travaille plus sur une
démarche d'intelligence aujourd'hui
qu'on n'a jamais fait par le passé
puisque ce qui nous intéresse c'est
comment on comprend c'est aujourd'hui le
savoir est à disposition et ce serait
illusoire de penser son lancinant pilat
ils arrivent en classe avec des
richesses de savoir quand avait
peut-être pas par le passé
en revanche on sait qu'il faut les
éduquer conscience le savoir avec des
outils et les outils qui demandent du
discernement
alors justement à certains endroits on
vient de me dire vous avez beaucoup
travaillé sur l'impact de ces outils sur
les enfants vous avez justement
différences et les écrans pour aider les
parents et vous avez fixer des repères
avec la règle des 3 6 9 12
c'est à dire pas d'écran avant trois
antennes avant trois pas de télé voilà
l'automobile voilà pas de console avant
6 ans pas d'internet avant neuf ans et
pas de réseaux sociaux avant de vous
expliquez nous comment vous avez pu
élaborer ces attaques il est utilisé aux
états unis aussi
oui oui tout à fait alors c'est pas une
règle que j'ai décidé un beau jour c'est
pas des balises que j'ai décidé un beau
jour tout seul ça correspond à l'état
des savoirs mais j'insiste à l'état des
savoirs au jour d'aujourd'hui
par exemple la console au jour
d'aujourd'hui elles l'ont l'utilisent
avec deux doigts ou trois ou quatre
doigts mais peut-être que dans l'avenir
on aura des consoles qui permettront
beaucoup plus d'utiliser toutes les
possibilités manuel on sait pas donc
c'est relatif à l'état actuel des
technologies telles que vous pensez de
motricité en fait oui la magistrate en
réduisant l'importance de la motricité
parce que un enfant peut s'isoler de
beaucoup d'autres façon qu en utilisant
une console donc il ya tout un travail à
faire pour socialiser l'enfant mais la
console n'est pas le seul obstacle que
l'enfant peut rencontrer sur la voie de
sa socialisation quand même voilà donc
oui 3 on sait que la télé pour l'enfant
moins trois ans ou si on préfère les
écrans non interactives donc télé dvd
etc
on sait que ça n'apporte rien l'enfant
ceci dit si des parents veulent regarder
un petit film 10 minutes tous les jours
avec leur tout petit et rire avec lui et
s'amuser avec lui pourquoi pas un voilà
mais voyez on est loin la de la télé
dans la chambre pour le tout petit c'est
ça contre quoi je voulais lui tes pattes
ailées avant trois ans et pas de télé
dans la chambre au delà mais pas avant
trois ans - alors si ce bon la console
de jeu wii la console de jeux si on joue
à plusieurs elle peut être intéressante
le problème c'est la console que
l'enfant a en propriété parce que là les
parents ne contrôle plus rien et on vous
dira même eu récemment un accident d'un
enfant qui allait à l'école avec sa
console il a été renversé par une
voiture parce que les parents et même
pas pensé à lui
enlevez qui la mettra dans son cartable
voyez donc ça c'est préoccupant leurs
neuf ans je sais que dans certaines
médiathèque des enfants vont sur
internet avant neuf ans mais c'est des
milieux très protégé un cdd logiciel qui
contrôle tout mais en pratique familiale
courante novembre et pas trop de raisons
d'aller sur internet avant et puis 11 12
ans c'est l'âge des réseaux sociaux
là encore il ya pas trop de raison d'y
aller 20 mais il faut comprendre que
sans citer 3 6 9 12 c'est le produit
d'appel on peut dire mais derrière 3 6 9
12 heures d'appels il ya quatre conseils
qui sont valables à tout âge
c'est limiter le temps d'écran c'est
choisir les programmes avec l'enfant
parce qu'on discute avec lui c'est
s'intéresser à ce qu'il fait sur les
écrans d'autres termes prendre le temps
d'en parler avec lui
l'académie américaine de pédiatrie vient
de découvrir que c'était important qu'on
sait c'est qu'elle chance effet
quatrième conseil c'est de de faire en
sorte que les pratiques de création
possible avec les outils numériques
soient encouragés par exemple vous vous
conseiller le premier portable qu'on
achète alors écoutez ça n'arrête pas là
je n'arrête pas de baisser
moi ce que je dis aux parents oui
maintenant et en plus maintenant sur les
parents se retrouver à praia smart one
ont pas voilà donc moi je dirais pas un
smartphone c'est à dire un téléphone
pour téléphoner mais pas un accès
illimité à internet quand même voilà et
puis il faut que les anc les parents
sachent que dès qu'ils ont acheté un
téléphone mobile à leurs enfants leurs
enfants s'éloignera beaucoup plus vite 2
est ce un bocal décélère beaucoup de
gens pensent le contraire non mais
beaucoup de parents dh est un smartphone
pour qu'ils puissent m'appeler et me
veut au contraire
oui le contraire l'enfant puisse dire à
ses copains il appellera plus ses
parents alors on parle aussi du
phénomène d'addiction aujourd'hui c'est
ce que ce qu'on redoute le plus
dominique billet et c'est qui qui est
touchée parce qu'on parle aussi beaucoup
de la fuite
l'addiction elle il ya des services
spécialisés qui se sont créés aussi vous
vous êtes confrontés dans l'enseignement
à ce genre de phénomène on en tant que
tel on peut pas dire qu'on est vraiment
confrontés
comme ça c'est surtout souvent à
domicile précisément les parents qui
sont si inquiets de style pour des plus
jeunes générations mais il faut bien
voir qu'en réalité ça peut aller la dh
beaucoup plus élevé 1 s'est pas limitée
aux enfants adolescents et en réalité
c'est un peu toujours le même problème
c'est à dire que vous voyez bien que le
potentiel d'un jeu en ligne par exemple
ou bien d'une d'une utilisation de
facebook
et contrairement à ce qu'on croit
quelquefois une aide pour éviter l'
isolement aisément et puis à un moment
quand vous passez au delà d'une certaine
limite c'est toujours un problème de
limite le seuil des choses comme ça de
proportionnalité j'allais dire de la
réponse est bien au bout d'un moment
vous embarquer dans une ce que les gens
appellent d'ailleurs vous devenez un no
life
si vous vivez dans un monde qui n'a plus
de connexion avec l'ensemble des des
types d'activités alors c'est pas
seulement avec la vraie vie qui serait
absolument idéal c'est pas le problème
et c'est surtout d'avoir une variété de
ses activités
et là le problème c'est qu'à ce moment
là on perd tous les avantages parce que
du coup c'est quelque chose qui peut
s'enrichir
on fait des jeux vidéo mois jean sèye en
faisant ça devient une ressource si vous
voulez mais si vous n'avez plus que ça
comme ressource bien évidemment votre
horizon cognitif autres horizons
d'apprentissage autorisons de
socialisation se rétrécit énormément
donc c'est le conseil que donne
serge j'en ai dit et ce serait pas là
pour des générations pour vous est-ce
qu'en fait les usages aujourd'hui le
reflet la fuite que certains trouvent à
travers à travers cet outil là serge
tisseron gratuit un nom bien sûr il ya
quand même une difficulté particulier la
transition dans laquelle on se trouve
s'attaquer aussi beaucoup des parents
qui sont démunis
tout simplement parce qu'on est souvent
à fronts renversés c'est à dire que les
enfants maîtrisent souvent mieux on va
dire en tout cas les usages généraux ont
pas reparlé d'ailleurs de ça et
notamment des tablettes mais vaut mieux
que leurs parents et donc on est en
situation qui est quand même assez
difficile faut bien le reconnaître dans
lequel du coup on a besoin d'éducation a
besoin de débat public précisément pour
aider les parents à comprendre parfois
des usages dont ils ne maîtrisent
absolument pas et parfois d'ailleurs
même très souvent ces enfants qui
apprennent à leurs parents en tout cas
les nouvelles technologies qui est qui
est maire donc on est en difficulté
quand même qui est très particulier
cette transition comme toi qui va durer
encore un bon paquet temps parce que
comme vous le disiez tout à l'heure les
recommandations vous faites vous même
elles sont liées complètement à l'état
de l'art des technologies actuellement
en mêlant deux ans dans cinq ans tout ça
peut être complètement bouleversé et
donc j'irai dire quand même une espèce
dallaire dans lequel on doit tous être a
fortiori pour des enfants parce que
évidemment ça va structurer leur
éducation mais je dirais pour nous mêmes
aussi d'interroger en permanence en fait
ces évolutions des usages tout
simplement pour regarder le meilleur et
puis pour en éloigner évidemment ce
qu'on faisait prendre alors il ya un
point qui est soulevé aussi dans votre
documentaire qui est assez intéressant
c'est l'impact sur les processus
cognitifs à serge tisseron je voulais
vous entendre là dessus par exemple sur
la mémoire les smartphones les tablettes
ouardi se substituerait à notre mémoire
on y prendrait comme mémoire externe et
donc les jeunes auraient plus de mal à
apprendre par coeur
qu'est ce qu'il en est vraiment de ça
vous savez au 3e siècle avant
jésus-christ y avait aussi un grand
débat là dessus sur l'écriture le fait
que l'écriture aller dramatiquement
appauvrir la mémoire bon et puis on
s'est aperçu que le livre on l'a intégré
dans nos vies et certaines choses on
fait travailler notre mémoire
et puis d'autres on la dépose dans le
livre dans l'écrit donc je pense que
très vite on va évoluer vers la même
logique c'est à dire qu'effectivement
notre mémoire tout un grand nombre de
choses que nous étions obligés de garder
en mémoire jusque là comme les numéros
de téléphone nous a mis des adresses des
codes etc
on va sens soulagé on va libérer de
l'espace mental pour faire autre chose
et tu vas maintenu et à utiliser notre
mémoire pour d'autres choses dans la
reconnaissance faciale des gens qu'on
connaît voilà le et de toute façon soul
et c'est un nouveau partage de la
mémoire il va se faire mais qu'il faut
pas s'inquiéter du fait que les
technologies prennent un relais
certaines de nos capacités parce
qu'elles l'ont tellement été inventée
par l'homme pour ça tout ce qui roule
nous permet de nous déplacer plus vite
d'un point à un autre nos vêtements ne
pas nous en rhumes et des secondes peaux
se faisait aussi à c'est aussi un
quelque part un nouveau fonctionnement
de notre cerveau
on perçoit les choses différemment et
1.6 sur les jeux vidéo et précisément
sur les jeux de guerre quand il est dit
dans le documentaire les joueurs ont
modifié leur perception d'autrui et ont
tendance à avoir des tendances au style
chez l'autre ça c'est un point qui peut
être inquiétant est ce que l'image
violente
ren piolenc est-ce qu'on voit l'autre
comme un ennemi c'est un vieux débat
mais c'est vrai que ce qui est ce qui
est pointé la est intéressant mais le
oui oui tout à fait lorsqu'il faut
comprendre déjà c'est que il y à pas mal
de jeunes qui jouent à des jeux violents
parce que c'est devenu un nouveau rituel
initiatique je propose pour caricaturer
les choses j'ai les filles en or règle
les garçons call of de la call of duty
voilà un jeu hyper violent on y joue
entre 11 et 13 ans éventuellement
apprend le laisse
mais à cet âge là on a l'impression
qu'on va devenir grand n'utilisant ça
donc il faut pas dramatiser les usages
de ces jeux par contre c'est qu'elle ne
joue qu'à ça pendant des années c'est
pour les batiks mais comme je dis
toujours le l'usagé intensif de jeu
hyper violent est un problème mais la
raison pour laquelle certains jeunes
s'enferment dans ces jeux hyper violent
et le premier problème pourquoi s'y
enferme utile parce que ils trouvent pas
dans l'environnement ce qui pourrait
attendre souvent pas de gratification
pas de reconnaissance solitude et donc
du coup c'est un cercle vicieux qui
s'installe à sentir seuls et délaissée
et avec un sentiment d'injustice ils
vont danser je puis en allant dans ces
jeux ils peuvent aggraver la
représentation d'un nom de beaucoup plus
méchant et beaucoup plus individualiste
que ce qu'il n'est en réalité mais c'est
le cercle vicieux qu'il faut comprendre
donc on va pas dire on va et et ses jeux
parce que ils vont trouver d'autres
activités d'un autre côté les études
montrent aussi les effets positifs
durables des jeux vidéo et à augmenter
la capacité à prendre des décisions
rapides et améliorait la créativité des
enfants
oui qu'est ce qu'être l'on sait que ça
me le fait que les jeux vidéo soit
aujourd'hui en tout cas pour une partie
d'entre inspirant pour le monde de
l'éducation pour faire répéter pour
apprendre la mer dire beaucoup plus
ludique et même évidemment en entreprise
montre bien que payés par des images
extrêmement intéressant je vends pour
transmettre du savoir pour entraîner
fait répéter des choses est ce à dire
il ya sûrement aujourd'hui et même des
détails ont parfois on regrette que
l'éducation nationale n'y avait pas plus
vite mais il ya des tas de manières
aujourd'hui d'apprendre l'orthographe
mieux que simplement pas d'édicter
régulière voilà il ya des choses
lieberman alors voilà et sophie est plus
mesuré et là dessus j'ai donné de ma
personne pour le coup en passant en irm
pour essayer de vous montrer un certain
nombre de choses sur l'apprentissage de
l'écriture je crois qu'il ya
effectivement un âge pour tout et je
crois que c'est important de savoir
faire les choses d'abord manuellement et
après de pouvoir les intégrer avec le
numérique mais que le numérique ne se
substitue pas à un apprentissage comme
ça pourrait être une tendance ou une
envie ou une facilité parce que ça reste
une facile celui dicté donc pas du tout
sa derbi
ça rebondit sur des débats qui a eu dans
les années 80 moi je me souviens qu'à
l'époque où moment il ya eu les
premières montres digitales
il ya eu tout un débat pour dire que
c'était un problème parce que c'était du
temps qu'on ne représentait plus part de
l'espace et qu'il était important
d'enseigner précisément et j'ai toujours
une montre voyez qu'il est donc c'est
très important de la même manière que je
pense comme comme les ai tout à l'heure
serge pense que dans dans le champ de
l'éducation
on a besoin des cartes et en fait on
peut effectivement poser problème et
mais en revanche le fait de soulagés par
exemple sachant qu'il ya sûrement
d'autres manière d'entraîner noir sur
d'autres choses mais se soulager d'accès
un certain nombre de savoir ne pense
n'est pas un problème
au contraire on va pouvoir déployer sur
autre chose des problèmes en d'ailleurs
que dans l'évolution humaine y aura des
recompositions dans notre cerveau qui
seront liées à ça en revanche je pense
qu'il y a des enseignements qui sont
structurants qui ont fait que nous
sommes des humains je pense que
l'alphabétisation par exemple je pense
que la représentation fallait il ya des
choses extrêmement simple par lesquels
on doit passer dans lequel on doit
passer de manière manuelle est pratiquée
et dans lequel pour moi le numérique ne
peut être que une manière d'entraîner de
vérifier de répéter sur des modes
ludiques ou là ça peut être intéressant
mais apprendre à écrire à prendre à
compte et faire des divisions ou autres
c'est des choses de base mon avis le
numérique ne remettra pas en cause par
contre permettra plus facilement de les
apprendre ça c'est possible
alors justement l'école on va en parler
on va écouter un extrait de documentaire
tout le monde est d'accord sur le fait
que le monde est maintenant numérique
quel enfant doit être adaptée au monde
du numérique
mais à aucun moment dans leur scolarité
on va leur enseigner comment fonctionne
selon le numérique au mieux pour
l'instant on leur apprend à interagir
avec des logiciels prêts existe il faut
qu'on trouve les moyens à l'école de
former les enfants à créer des outils
numériques et pas seulement les
utilisent alors dominique boullier vous
j'ai lu vous dit
internet doit être une révolution
pédagogique
vous vous dites que les digital natives
ont l'habitude d'être actif en ligne et
donc ils ne peuvent plus rester assise
par exemple dans une classe à écouter
qu'ils ont besoin de faire qu'est ce que
vous constatez vous et comment vous
pensez cette révolution pédagogique
aujourd'hui encore on constate justement
cette attractivité très important des
activités en ligne qui soit en jeux
vidéo en réseau autrement
un peu comme le disait serge
effectivement on peut s'interroger sur
le fait que sans doute qu'il y ait un
rapport avec le fait que les situations
dans lesquelles sont les enfants
habituellement sont particulièrement
dépourvu d'incitation de d'encouragement
d'exploration et qu'on est dans les
mains dans des postures qui finalement
les ennuie profondément et donc
évidemment on peut que réfléchir à tout
cela quand on voit à partir de ce moment
là quand on prend en compte ce que peut
apporter une certaine aspect soit des
jeux vidéo soit du numérique en général
et bien à ce moment là on peut se dire
qu'il ya possibilité de se désinscrire
dans un processus d'apprentissage qui
font par exemple quand on parle des jeux
vidéo tout à l'heure on voit
effectivement il ya des situations de
multi-activités où ils deviennent bien
meilleur que tout ce qu'on peut faire et
on peut pas pédagogiquement réellement
construire des situations de ce type là
la multi-activité c'est un une qualité
certains vont dire ah oui mais ça veut
dire qu'ils font plus attentifs aux
profs se désole le propre pendant que le
prof parle en général ils font déjà
beaucoup d'autres choses c'est quand
même quelque chose qu'on le constate et
surtout ce qui est important c'est de
pouvoir le proposer un parcours
pédagogique pour sa qui exploite ce
potentiel la même façon que la
résolution de problèmes ou la mise en
situation réaliste ça c'est des choses
qu'on a du mal à mettre en place sans
les supports pédagogiques que tu prête
moi j'utilise par exemple sim city pour
faire mes étudiants qui sont de futurs
dirigeants de grandes villes bien ils
doivent en situation ils doivent se
mettre en situation et c'est ça qui est
intéressant ça veut pas dire pour ça
qu'ils passent des heures et des heures
ils ont un protocole assez précis ils
doivent expérimenter cela il ressort des
choses qui sont difficiles à faire
passer sur le plan des logiques de façon
comment diable descendante alors que là
ils sont dans une situation où ils
voient tous les événements qui se
passent dans une ville en des décisions
etc
si vous le cadre est de cette façon là
il le se rend compte que c'est un plus
mais à condition évidemment de bien
enclenché un scénario pédagogique qui va
avec
si c'est seulement dire allez-y et puis
moi je ne fais que j'ai plus rien à
faire et vous vous débrouillez et
l'enseignant disparaît on se rend compte
que ça fait flop
soit ça soit fait flop sur plan des
connaissances ou alors ça marche très
bien mais alors ça marche très bien vous
partenaires dans une logique où vous
êtes complètement immergé dans ces jeux
et puis c'est terminé vous ne vous en
vous ne savez même pas ce que vous en
tirez réellement que penser de ce que
prône de cet enseignant dans le
documentaire maman et de la suppression
de l'écriture manuscrite est ce qu'on
n'est pas dans l'excès apparemment ya
des états américains où il naît on n'est
plus obligé d'apprendre à écrire à la
main comment cette ça parce que c'est
assez étonnant quand même voilà c'est ma
requête ça m'inquiète pression pour la
raison que j'essaie de dire un peu avant
c'est à dire que on ne sait pas quelles
sont les conséquences en réalité de ces
choix pédagogiques et donc je serais
extrêmement prudents sur ces jeux là je
pense qu'il faut laisser en fait la
liberté tout simplement on peut et on
doit apprendre à écrire manière
manuscrite et qu'on apprenne aujourd'hui
est inclus je pense qu'on a intérêt à
faire attention la même manière je
prenais l'exemple tout à l'heure je
pense qu'il ya des choses qui nous ont
structuré cognitivement dont on sait
qu'elles sont structurantes
l'alphabétisation
c'est un changement majeur dans
l'histoire de l'humanité l'écriture je
pense qu'on a on doit faire extrêmement
attention à tout ce qu'on va bouger là
dessus en revanche ensuite on a plein de
palettes de pouvoir on va dire quand
même un peu modernisé la pédagogie c'est
vrai que on en a parlé depuis le début
la transmission du savoir devient
probablement moins importante qu'elle ne
l'a été et donc le mode un peu magistral
vous avez un programme une autorité qui
va déverser un contenu sans se soucier
d'ailleurs toujours très bien parce que
faute de moyens de la perception de ceux
de cette connaissance comment elle et
comment les ailes et ingurgité par les
élèves comme l ai travaillé réfléchi et
c'est bon ça c'est clair que ce mode là
certainement est déjà en cours au fond
de l'explosion il était déjà pas fait
non plus que ça mais c'est certainement
en réduction pour autant ya quand même
d'autres modes plus collaboratif plus de
réflexion plus dans l'expérimentation
qui vont prendre la place une solution
mais c'est très clair que sur
l'apprentissage de l'écriture
il faut apprendre à écrire
je crois qu'il ya un certain nombre
d'expériences qui montre aujourd'hui que
c'est fondamental et il faut vraiment
pas se poser la question de savoir si on
va apprendre à écrire avec un clavier ou
à la main si on arrive à se poser ce
genre de question je pense que
effectivement là il ya un danger
donc il ya des études qui l'ont prouvé
en chine ils ont mis des tablettes dans
beaucoup de ces réserves est un bon
signe non pas le couteau
oui mais pendant des années ils ont
appris à écrire comme ça et c'est comme
ça qu'on s'en souvient et cette
expérience de jean luc boulay à
marseille qui montrent qu'effectivement
dans des classes de maternelle quand on
apprend à écrire à la main et quand on
apprend uniquement à reconnaître les
touches sur un clavier ça fait pas appel
aux mêmes aux mêmes fonctions du cerveau
et on se souvient mieux quand on est
amené à écrire à la main donc là je
crois que c'est important de garder cet
ordre là en phase achetés seront il faut
bien comprendre l'idée qu'ont les
américains quand ils décident que les
enfants voir prendre sur clavier c'est
de faire du langage de programmation des
machines une langue étrangère parmi
toutes les langues
c'est à dire qu'en fait on apprend à
écrire les langues et on apprend à
écrire le langage de programmation et
d'autre part il ya dans l'apprentissage
de l'écriture à la main tout un aspect
de psychomotricité de motricité fine
d'élaboration du geste qui peut être
pris en relais par d'autres activités
lors de toute façon aussi aux états unis
font rien sans l'évaluer donc dans
quelques années
oui pour les conséquences on abordera
entre l'enseignement de la programmation
et du code et là oui on va y venir sur
le code ça c'est encore un autre sujet
moi je parlais je parlais juste de
l'apprendre à écrire à la main mais il
faut quand même savoir que le clavier
qu'on nous présente comme une la panacée
c'est quand même quelque chose qui était
un inventeur 1870 et qui est très mal
fait on le sait que sur le plan
ergonomique s'est fait précisément pour
ralentir
donc ça a été fait pour ça à l'époque
donc qu'on soit encore dans cette idée
là moi je n'ai pas rien j'ai rien contre
l'idée qu'on est un nouvel outil est
celui là il est un des plus mauvais on
peut envisager ce qui est extraordinaire
qui montrent la plasticité des humains
qui sont prêts à s'adapter à quelque
chose de très mal conçus pour eux mais
est-ce qu'on doit continuer à dire toute
une civilisation basculement sein de
pour adopter un outil qui en réalité est
très très mal faite
là il ya quand même des limites
mais je peux être imaginons autre chose
toute façon d'écrire sans doute mais
certainement pas celle là de mon point
de vue la tablette à l'école les enfants
évidemment sont très enthousiastes
on peut y voir un formidable moyen de
renforcer le plaisir d'apprendre qu'elle
juste place lui donner est ce que par
exemple la tablette doit jouer un rôle
dans l'apprentissage de la lecture ou
est ce que la tablette doit jouer un
autre rôle dans la pédagogie scolaires
qui vont réagir s'achèteront oui alors
je sais qu'aujourd'hui il ya un gros
effort des collectivités locales pour
introduire des tablettes
chaque enfant sa tablette à mon avis
c'est pas la bonne idée parce que je
crois que ce qui est propre à l'outil
numérique
c'est le travail à plusieurs et que en
introduisant un outil numérique par
enfant on risque d'induire l'enfant vers
l'idée que l'outil numérique c'est un
usage personnel individuel au travail en
dessous et bien il faut qu'il tournait
alors pour travailler en groupe ils
n'ont pas besoin d'avoir une tablette
chacun derniers temps c'est dans un
premier temps je pense que ce qui est
important c'est qu'ils apprennent à
travailler à plusieurs
face à un écran et ensuite travaillé
ensemble par des écrans interconnectés
et puis ensuite on leur dit ben voilà
maintenant vous allez travailler que le
monde entier via internet
je pense qu'on peut pas à la fois
regretté que des enfants s'isole devant
l'écran et en même temps valoriser
l'idée qu'on va remplacer le livre et le
cahier qu'à chaque élève par le fait que
chaque élève est une tablette est
question de remplacer je crois pas à ces
seize noms l'occasion surtout de trouver
un petit peu comme dit serge fait de
trouver une solution aux problèmes
pédagogiques que l'on a contemporain
d'apprentissage et de diversification
des types d'apprentissage de trop penser
qu'on a trouvé une solution en
distribuant des outils des dispositifs
comme cela le problème on peut à la
limite si on dit elle cette tablette
avec les réserves que fait certes il y
aurait aussi des mais quelle application
faire croire qu'elle est la piste
pédagogique c'est pour ça que je
considère que tablette ou pas tant qu'il
ya zéro créativité pédagogique ici c'est
courant quand craindre et récupérer les
savoirs de la même façon qu'on fait
c'est égal à zéro et les résultats de
diffusion dans les départements de tous
ces outils là avant les tablettes ça a
été les ordinateurs aussi et c'est
personnel
personnel qui a été et est limité
d'ailleurs des activités pédagogiques ne
sont pas brillants si aujourd'hui rage
et l'industrie c'est pour ça que la
question du support est moins
intéressante que la question en réalité
des contenus mais ils sont pas
suffisants aujourd'hui est en tout cas
qui sont pas suffisamment maîtrisé dans
le cas par exemple officielle d'une
institution de l'éducation nationale il
ya du travail à faire avant de se poser
la question des supports comme les
questions qu'elle est contenue est-ce
que c'est efficace ou pas quel chouette
mais il ya une deuxième question mois de
l'intérieur derrière la tablette
parce que c'est un débat quand même
qu'ils qui revient et là il revient
d'ailleurs demandé à mon avis à des âges
différents
je pense que la tablette a quand même un
inconvénient majeur c'est que c'est
quand même
au global un outil en tout cas on va
dire pour on va dire à partir du collège
au minimum c'est comme un outil
relativement passif vous êtes un
consommateur d'application alors si
c'est des bonnes applications qui ont
été choisis par des profs conçu validé
par par des pédiatres et des
psychologues etc et que ça prouve que
c'est intéressant est pas bonne et qu'il
faut pas les utiliser encore que faudra
utiliser avec d'autres modes
pédagogiques du magistral du parti
native du collectif etc
ça viendra évidemment mais il faut pas
trop s'illusionner sur la question de la
tablette parce qu'encore une fois
j'insiste par rapport à un ordinateur
une tablette reste un outil de
consommation ou n'écrirai jamais une
dissertation pour prendre un exemple
simple vous n'écrirez jamais une
dissertation ou vous ne feriez une thèse
ou vous ne ferez de la programmation
informatique sur une tablette
on peut rajouter un clavier tard avant
la fin de la transformer en débatteur je
veux dire par là c'est quand même c'est
un outil spécifique de support et que
c'est quand même assez différent
dernière oui il faudrait aussi que dans
le l'idée de généraliser les tablettes
il ya l'idée que les livres papier ne
seront plus donner aux élèves en leur
permettra de les télécharger sur leur
tablette est donc l'idée c'est de faire
des économies considérables
alors si ces économies sont utilisés
pour former des enseignants à
l'utilisation des tablettes
tant mieux mais j'ai pas l'impression
qu'il en soit question est aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'enseignants laisse les
tablettes de côté ou éventuellement des
aux élèves écoutent et il reste 5
minutes de cours sortez vos tablettes
c'est de faire quelque chose donc ça
c'est catastrophique les tablettes ne
sont sont amusés je suis d'accord avec
benoît un ordinateur avec clavier qui
permet d'écrire est évidemment offre
évidemment beaucoup plus d'eux
deux possibilités de création qu'une
tablette où on utilise les appuis
existants autre question très actuelle
et on l'a évoqué le code donné vouliez
j'ai lu vous disais moi je ne suis pas
pour qu'on apprenne le code parce
qu'encore une fois apprendre à maîtriser
l'outil c'est pouvoir créer des outils
ou dit je suis moins pour le code que
pour l'algorithmique alors expliquez
nous expliquez-nous pour les films en
lice et intel
le problème c'est que quand on dit on va
enseigner le code et ça veut dire alors
évidemment on reste le clavier mais
après on dit quoi weeks alors quel type
de langage on ya des langages il y en a
qui sont extrêmement compilé qui sont
des langages objets qui sont de haut
niveau et qui ne vous oblige pas à
rentrer dans les mêmes détails que les
lits langage qu'on avait il ya vingt ans
je veux dire ça c'est clair
et qu'est ce qu'on s'est désolé engage
actuelle par rapport à ce qui sera
nécessaire dans le temps on a un vrai
problème d'orientation pédagogique qu'on
doit t'on à prendre maintenant quand on
sait que de toute façon ce savoir la
sera disqualifié dans 15 ans dans dix
quinze ans et ça c'est un problème alors
que l'algorithmique c'est pour ça que je
reviens là dessus elle doit mixer
seulement apprendre à organiser des
procédures à penser en découpant des
opérations en pensant les effets et
l'ensemble des relations qui lient à les
états d'un système tout ça c'est des
choses que l'on veut faire céder très
proche de la logique et on peut le faire
de façon très dans la vie quotidienne
aussi et ça devrait être là par contre
indispensable et je pense que ça
favoriserait même le rapprochement avec
les mathématiques puisqu'on a un vrai
problème mais vous dites faudrait
rénover les loges
je pense qu'ils ont un vrai problème là
dessus c'est à dire qu'elles sont moins
attractives
actuellement ce qui est catastrophique
et du point de vue du développement
général d'un pays puis la culture en
général de la capacité de citoyens y
compris à se réapproprier tout cela mais
pour ça il faut sans doute qu'on admette
que justement il ya des noyaux danse et
de connaissances si vous voulez qu'ils
sont valables il faut pas s'exciter sur
l'ensemble des comment dire des
innovations techniques il faut savoir
pourquoi on veut transformer réellement
une capacité de prise donne une vraie
capacité de prise et qui soit durable le
problème c'est ça c'est qu'à l'école on
est obligé de choisir quand même des
investissements qu'ils soient un peu
durable on peut pas surfer sur toutes
les innovations il a il faut faire des
priorités et donc moi c'est pour ça que
je considère que apprendre à concevoir
un algorithme à penser de façon
algorithmique ça c'est utile pour
et groupe bigard oui cela étant dit
c'est vrai qu'on en parle moins cela
étant dit pour revient un peu à quel
objectif derrière on a parlé des gitanes
et ids pendant quelques années on a pu
croire que les digital natives allait
être la génération spontanée du
numérique qui a l'a parfaitement
comprendre ce nouveau monde dans lequel
on allait se mouvoir au fond nous les
migrants s'amener après on allait vite
se faire dépasser aujourd'hui le recul
qu'on a parce qu'on commence à voir du
recul pour le coup dit plus tôt l'
inverse c'est à dire que les digital
natives savent manier les usages très
bien j'ai effectivement il aurait collé
une tablette
qu'importe que le coc fois à des âges
assez sidérant ça s'en servir ils
apprennent très bien et c'est et ils ont
peut-être plus vite que vous et moi pour
manier un certain usage en revanche pour
panser ses usages
là pour le coup désolé mais nous qui
sommes migrants qui avons eu la chance
d'être dans deux mondes un peu différent
qui interrogeons ces usages là et puis
qui avons aussi la maturité d'être un
peu plus âgés ont réfléchi sur ces
sujets là et on un rapport critique est
beaucoup plus distant et donc je pense
que l'enjeu c'est quoi au fond c'est
justement de faire en sorte qu'on ne
fabrique pas une génération de
dépendants qui au fond se sert de ses
incroyables de manière passive et de
manière je dirais presque magique cirque
en gros qui se disent c'est quelque
chose de naturel on appuie sur un bouton
il ya un truc qui arrive sans
s'interroger au fond de caisse kitase et
si vous réfléchissez deux secondes
l'école jules-ferry quand elle a été
fondée elle répondait au fond à deux
problématiques prometic citoyenne on est
dans une démocratie qu'on installe
endroit enseigne apprennent à vivre
ensemble et à rafah société c'est un
sujet à mon avis il a son pendant
numérique
mais un deuxième en jeu dont on a un peu
moins parler c'était aussi fabriquer des
cadres pour la révolution industrielle
qui était en cours c'est à dire lui
faire comprendre au fond le monde
économique la transmission c'est au
moment où on commence on a construit des
rails ya la mécanique électricité qui
arrive et c'est tard et tout ces
enseignements l'a progressivement ils
ont fait leur entrée à l'école pour que
vous compreniez que quand vous allumez
une voiture mais c'est pas une espèce de
magie de transcendance qui fait que ça
avance mais simplement voilà et tout le
monde autour de cette table
même si ce n'est pas spécial du
mécanique comme une vague idée de ce que
c'est qu'un moteur à combustion interne
laissant ce qui se provoque etc on ne
les a pas tous réparer une voiture
on a tous au minimum une compréhension
et c'est ça au fond la question qui est
posée à nos sociétés c'est de faire en
sorte que les enfants comprennent donc
deux choses 1 le hardware le matériel
comment ça fonctionnait qu'est ce que
c'est que cette science des machines
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un ordinateur
la mémoire par brille d'ailleurs qui
permettra de mieux comprendre comment
nous mêmes on fonctionne parfois et la
deuxième chose donc au dessus de la
couche hardware un des supports de ya la
couche logicielle comprendre ce que
c'est qu'un logiciel comprend ce que
c'est qu'une programmation leur ensuite
peut discuter ce que ces hybrides parce
que c'était le langage ou tel autre moi
j'ai fait classique à l'école par perdre
personne ne sait aujourd'hui ce que
c'est mais ça m'apprend le mans a pris
un peu en amont d'ailleurs ce que
c'était logiciel est ce que ça veut dire
parce que le numéro et on arrive bientôt
à terme du débat mais heureusement le
numérique c'est une réponse aussi
potentiel à nos besoins économiques on
dit que un million d'emplois devraient
être créés dans le numérique en europe
d'ici dix ans est ce que ça veut dire
des nouvelles formations dans
l'enseignement supérieur pour pouvoir
aboutir à de nouveaux emplois est ce que
ça veut dire qu'il ya beaucoup d'emplois
aujourd'hui qui n'existe pas et qui vont
être créés en réponse à ces besoins la
wii le problème c'est qu'on risquerait
de se focaliser en disant il nous faut
des emplois d'informaticiens
le numérique c'est quand même assez
diversifié ses urines on a besoin par
exemple de producteurs de contenus de
créateurs de la création on consomme des
contenus en quantité est-ce que ça ça
fait partie des des bases de ce qu'on
peut enseigner aussi et moi jean sèye et
je me pousse les étudiants n'ont plus à
faire des rangs du papier ma produire
des vidéos
j'ai l'impression de faire autant ma
contribution je lire à l'eau
développement technique et économique de
mon pays en faisant ça pourquoi parce
qu'on a besoin de gens qui savent écrire
le en numérique j'allais dire avec les
outils numériques et écrire ça veut dire
scénarisé raconter des histoires avec
les supports que l'on a c'est pas
toujours se focaliser sur l'informatique
je suis d'accord qu'il en faut il en
faudrait quelque part oui il ya plus une
palette de compétences qui sur lesquels
il faut interdire ou d'applications
possibles on en voit dans le film de
anne sophie avec les personnes âgées en
hôpital ça veut dire développer des
programmes particuliers développer des
interfaces homme-machine particulière
développer des nouvelles professions les
accompagnateurs de ses activités donc il
ya énormément d'opportunités me voyez
pas seulement technologique de métier ça
peut aussi réconcilier par exemple est
ce qu'on peut penser différemment le
lycée professionnel par exemple avec ça
est-ce que ça peut ça peut être une
façon justement de rendre à nouveau
attractif ce lycées ces formations bien
sûr le problème c'est que effectivement
le sait surtout est ce qui est en jeu
dans les discussions qui assure
enseigner la programmation
surtout précisément qu'on récupère dans
tout enseignement une idée d'activité de
savoir faire alors qu'on en est
seulement à ses parents radicalement
enseignement professionnel pour les uns
qui vont se retrouver déclassé
socialement et pour les autres c'est
seulement du discours et de la mémoire
qu'on va répéter alors que si on prenait
au sérieux le fait qu apprendre à faire
donc ça veut dire à faire des machines à
fait à développer des choses et il à
faire collectivement et c'est là si on
le prenait partout au sérieux sans doute
que le statut de l'enseignement
professionnel changerait or jusqu'ici on
se dit ah oui on va pas apprendre à tout
le monde à manipuler une fraiseuse bon
d'accord ok on pourrait on avait cet
argument là maintenant on peut le faire
avec le numérique c'est ça qui peut être
un avantage pour dire apprenez à faire
et à faire collectivement en plus là il
y aurait une dynamique qui transforme l
ensemble de m'enseigner caisse avec ses
mains autant que déjà les jeudis au
japon où il fabrique des petits robots
dans les écoles oui est ce que justement
ce mot de faire assaut final à vous
réconcilier un petit peu et ce que ça
bouge ça vous vous accroche à cet
univers c'est parce que finalement c'est
ça vous qui vous inquiète c'est
s'asseoir iront heureux ou a fait c'est
ça ce qui rend heureux dans la vie ce
qui est gratifiant c'est de savoir faire
quelque chose et c'est ça qui nous donne
la liberté plus on sait faire deux
choses plus on se sent libre
regardez un enfant qui arrive avec
quelque chose qu'il a fait lui même
comme il est heureux regardez vous quand
vous savez faire quelque chose que ce
soit de la cuisine tout ce que vous
pouvez faire avec vos mains mais ça rend
heureux c'est ça c'est très important
c'est une réponse de la promesse au fond
des pères fondateurs de l'internet
oui profondément ont vu une révolution
de lymphome de l'an pouvoir m'en le mec
donne du pied par aux gens du pouvoir
pour l'essentiel pour être actif pour
maîtriser un certain de choses pour
trouver un peu n'importe quel type de
contenu d'informations de connaissances
et de pratiques donc on est vraiment au
tout début d'une redistribution des
cartes de pouvoir effectivement demain
ceux dont on aura besoin ce soit - la
maîtrise d'une connaissance spécifique
qu'on pourra toujours aller trouver
quelque part mais de sa maîtrise est par
ailleurs je pense que là pour le coup
dans un monde quand même économique plus
on est dans une abondance d'informations
on va dire numérique - elle a de très
grande valeur et plus on revient dans la
valeur profonde des choses c'est à dire
la présence
je pense que ça va revenir quelque chose
entre ma première mâcon regard réguler
davantage mais aussi mais aussi la
fabrication de produits autres je pense
que l'art
anna le do it yourself ou le mouvement
internet pour en réalité est
profondément appuyé par action donc le
numérique remet aussi l'humain au coeur
du débat
c'est très bien on continue à en
discuter marchés où nous ont choisis on
y veille laitiers on continue le débat
reste ouvert
merci à tous d'être venus sur ce plateau
la semaine prochaine vous retrouvez
laurent bazin pour un documentaire qui
retrace le parcours d'un jeune
trisomique dans le monde du travail
et quant à moi je vous attends dans
quinze jours pour un débat sur la place
des femmes dans la religion à tradition
public sénat
oh